we're here for asian heritage month and
this ties really nicely into something
that i like to ask all the pro wrestlers
that i talk to
i usually ask them for their four
favorite or four greatest
superstars in a certain category so i
thought today it makes sense to ask you
oscar
who are the four greatest asian pro
wrestlers in history
not named oscar oh yeah there are many
greatest asian wrestlers in the world
when i was a teenager i was not
listening on the tv
because our japanese wrestlers were um
fearless and patient
so they gave me energy and
courage so i want to entertain
a lot of people um like they did for me
are there are there any names are there
any favorites you had
yes a great mural so japanese restaurant
she is so good so cool and
yes yes and you can see the influence
with the mask and everything
now if i'm not mistaken with the
exception of bulnakano
you are i think regardless of gender
only the second
japanese world champion if we're
excluding nxt
in wwe how does it feel
to think about the fact that you know i
think a lot of people would say oscar is
the
most accomplished the most successful
japanese wrestler
in wwe history period how does it feel
to think that you know uh
japanese girls watching wwe can say wow
one day i can be like oscar
oh yeah i wanna i wanna say
to uh asian girls i don't
don't give up on your dream
so yeah when i was at 16
i wanna be uh i wanted to be a
wwe superstar one day i
um i asked my mom can i be a wwe
superstar
she said no you have to go to college
okay then um i also tell i told
um my high school teacher
i want to be a wwe superstar he laughed
and said um don't be silly
okay i was shocked and
yeah i had no choice and um
yeah i gave up on my dream once
then i went to college and after
graduating
from college but i
turned 20 i couldn't give up on my dream
so then my friends
gave me confidence and you can do it you
can do it
then i okay i got it i called
um listening company in tokyo and i left
my hometown osaki japan so i'm
now i'm with superstar
so yeah i don't
give up on your dream
that's beautiful and uh the energy is
infectious i know at one point in your
wrestling career you retired right
because of some health problems
what how what was the changing point
where you said no it's okay i'm feeling
better i'm going to try this again
yes um yeah
my uh i had a problem
um but i wanna
yeah i wanna entertain a lot of people
yeah it's my uh goal
so yeah then
my mother told me yeah you have to
fight again so then
i'm good yeah i'm glad your mother came
around there and started supporting you
um oscar is it okay if we talk a little
bit about
the violence that we've seen lately
against uh asian people
around the world yeah i hate it
i hate it uh i don't understand
uh um it's a waste of time to be
hateful so yeah why
people attack other people
we are all people right yeah
i don't understand i hate it uh
would you be willing to share any of
your own experiences
experiences with racism excuse me yes
yes i have
uh yeah only one
experience with resin
so it was about a time
when kobe 19 started spreading
in america i was at
the airport a woman came
become became toward me
when she
noticed me she covered
her mouth with her hand
and ran away from me
i was shocked so ah
it it never happened before
copy 19 oh my gosh i did
i didn't understand and uh but uh
yeah i was shocked well i'm sorry you
experienced that and i want to
thank you for you you don't have to talk
to me about this stuff so i thank you
for doing that
um what advice would you give to
non-asian people who want to support
their asian friends and
asian communities what should they do uh
i think it's important to import
for known asians to
understand and share
the wonderful culture of
asian well and that's
the perfect segue because it's asian
heritage month and i want to celebrate
that i was going to ask you
what is something about japanese culture
that you love
that people maybe don't know about don't
know about yeah um
japanese culture so yeah i love
japanese culture such as souls such as
anime and anime
manga cars and
video games and
so i also love
japanese food such as sushi sashimi
sukiyaki takuyaki and i love
beautiful nature so yeah
then uh some some japanese
uh some american people tell me
they love japanese
anyway yeah such as
yeah dragon ball naruto or something
then i'm proud
of being japanese
perfect and you know i want to point to
that i got my pokemon back here
i've got my edward l rick full metal
alchemist right here
some people said shaquille take those
down it's uh
not professional but i'm glad i kept
them up uh
what is so great about i know but tell
the people who don't know what is so
great about anime oh good
anime oh graphic
is beautiful and it sounds good
um yeah
so far and the story is so
good yeah i'm
always uh watching
anime and the movie
but also i love american dramas
so i think it's important for
import to enjoy
and share and respect
each other's culture as we start to wrap
up here
i do want to talk a little bit about
your wwe career i was watching
listening to an interview with ria
ripley of course you shared the ring
with her at wrestlemania
and you will do so again at wrestlemania
backlash on may 16th
rhea said that she watched you wrestle
when she was 19 years old and from that
day she had been waiting for the day
that she can finally wrestle oscar
is there anyone in the wwe or beyond
that you haven't wrestled yet that you
would really like to share the ring with
what do you mean is there anyone you
want to wrestle that you've never
wrestled before
i wanna risk
the way triple h
okay let's make it happen
i know he's a big fan of you so
yeah and uh require
okay i love it let's make it happen yeah
and uh
yeah i fought many great research
uh great uw superstar
so oh um
ronda rousey i like it
once i think she's having a baby but
after that
one day one day fingers crossed okay
last question oscar
i i mentioned at the top of the show you
are i think without a doubt
the most accomplished japanese wrestle
in wwe
is there anything you still want to
achieve are there any goals you haven't
yet
achieved oh yes um
so all all
people all over the world are watching
wwe
so
i my goal
at wwe is to
to get more people
to know me and
i want to share a wonderful of
wonderful culture of japanese japan and
asia as an asian
that's perfect there's no better note to
end on oscar i want to thank you so much
for your time
congratulations on all you've achieved
so far in the wwe
and i look forward for what's left to
come thank you so much i had fun
hey me too